[موسيقى]
من المحيط الى الخليج تعاني معظم الدول
العربيه
التغير المناخي فلنطقه العربيه التي تواجه
العديد من الازمات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه هي ايضا الاكثر
عرضه لتاثيرات تغير المناخ استمر بدوره من
الجفاف والفيضانات وموجات حرار لم يسبق
لها مثيل على مدى العقود الثلاثه الماضيه
شهدت هذه المنطقه ارتفاعا في درجات
الحراره بشكل اسرع بكثير من المتوسط
العالمي وفقا للامم المتحده ومن المتوقع
ان تصبح حالات الجفاف فيها اكثر توادرا
وشده خلال سنوات المقبله فما هي سبل
التصدي لهذه التغيرات والحد من مخاطرها في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا وكيف
ستبدا المنتخب
وتناقص مواردها المائيه اهلا بكم في هذه
الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم من السوري والفيضانات الى
موجات الحر وحرائق الغابات اصبحت اثار
التغير المناخي ملموسه في جميع انحاء
العالم ومع تفاقم ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري
والانبعاثات الصناعيه حذرت منظمات دوليه
من التداعيات الخطيره للتغير المناخي
مؤكده على الحاجه الحيويه لوضع اليات
للتكيف مع هذا المعطي الجديد
عن التحديات التي تواجهها منطقتنا العربيه
بسبب التغيرات المناخيه والاثاث
المستقبليه للتخفيف منحتها يسعدنا ان يكون
معنا في هذه الحلقه بهولندا نجيب صعب
الامين العام للمنتدى العربي للبيئه
والتنميه والرئيس تحرير مجله البيئه
والتنميه من تطوان بالمغرب الدكتور زين
العابدين الحسيني استاذ التشريع البيئي
والتنميه المستدامه ومن لندن كريم الجندي
الخبير في شؤون البيئه والمناخ في المعهد
الملكي للشؤون الدوليه شتمها
بهم جميعا
قبل اياما على بدء اعمال مؤتمر المناخ في
شرم الشيخ والذي يختتم اعماله الجمعه حذرت
منظمه جريبيس البيئيه في تقرير لها مطلع
هذا الشهر من اثار من سلبيه للتغير
المناخي على منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وبالاضافه الى هذا التقرير
تتوقعوا دراستنا علميه اخرى ان تتفاقم
الاوضاع في هذه المنطقه بسبب غياب التعاون
المشترك بين بلدانها للبحث عن حلول لهذه
التحديات
تحت عنوان على شفير الهاويه قالت منظمه
جرين بيس ان منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا تشهد احترارا بما يقرب من ضعف
المتوسط العالمي العمر الذي يعرضها للتاثر
بشكل كبير بتغير المناخ وجاء في التقرير
ان ملايين السكان في المنطقه سيواجهون
خطره شو حلم المياه وموجات الحره
والفيضانات وغيرها من الاثار السلبيه
للتغير المناخي
وحدد التقرير سته بلدان هي المغرب
والجزائر وتونس ومصر ولبنان والامارات
وقالوا انها ستعاني من خطر كبير لشح
المياه الامر الذي سوف يؤثر سلبا على
الزراعه وفقا للتقرير تعتمد المنطقه على
الواردات الغذائيه التي يمكن ان تتاثر في
حال اكثر الجفاف وندره المياه على
المحاصيل في العقود المقبله واشار الى انه
بحلول نهايه القرن من المرجح ان تعاني 80%
على المدن المقتضه بالسكان في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من موجات حر شديده
وفي ظل وجود انبعاثات عاليه في بعض
المواقع بالشرق الاوسط ومنطقه الخليج يمكن
ان تتجاوز درجات الحراره القصوى خلال
موجات الحر الشديده في المستقبل
56 درجه مئويه بحسب التقرير
[موسيقى]
في مدينه ساحليه جميله مثل الاسكندريه
تشير توقعات الامم المتحده الى ان مليونير
شخص قد يكرهون للنزوح داخليا بسبب ارتفاع
متوقع في منسوب مياه البحر المتوسط بحلول
العام 2050
وفقا اكثر سيناريوهات تفاؤلات فان ثلث
المدينه قد يصبح حينها تحت الماء او غير
صالح للسكن
ليست حاله مصريه فقط يقول البنك الدولي
انه ما لم يتم العمل على الحد من الاسباب
التغيرات المناخيه فين الدول الخمسه في
شمال افريقيا ستشهد نزوح
2006 مليون شخص داخل بلدانهم بحلول 2050
يؤيد هذا الطرح تقرير للمؤسسه الاوروبيه
للمتوسط ذكر ان هذه المنطقه اكثر من غيرها
عرضه للاخطار لان شواطئها كثيفه السكان
وهي مهدده بارتفاع مستوى مياه البحر
ليست هذه وحدها الاخطار المناخيه المهبقه
باقليم حوض البحر الابيض المتوسط تم تتطور
تاريخي رصده خبراء البيئه في ارتفاع درجات
الحراره بهذه البلدان خلال العقود الاخيره
اثاره على البيئه وحياه الناس اكثر من ان
تحصى يكفي ان نتوقف ماليا عند تاثيراتها
على الغذاء
تقول دراسه لجامعه التكنولوجيا في
سنغافوره عنوانها تاثير التغير المناخي
على انتاج الغذاء تقول ان كل زياده في
درجات الحراره قدرها درجه مئويه الواحده
تؤدي الى انخفاض الانتاجيه بنسبه 10%
التي استضافت دوره هذا العام من مؤتمر
المناخ عرضه كما يقول الخبراء لان تفقد
نصف انتاجيه قطاعها الزراعي بحلول العام
2060 خطر يحدق مثله بالعراق الذي يشهد
درجات حراره قياسيه خلال السنوات الاخيره
بحسب البنك الدولي فانه قد يفقد نسبه 20%
من مياه العذبه بحلول 2050 في حال ارتفاع
الحراره بمقدار درجه مئويه واحده وانخفاض
الامطار بنسبه 10%
هذه اصغر عينه ممكنه لملامح التهديدات
التي تحيط بالمنطقه العربيه من اثار
الاحتباس الحراري وتغيرات المناخ منذ قمه
باريس للمناخ عام 2015 توقع خبراء لهيئه
الدوليه المعنيه بتغيير المناخ ان تشهد
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا ارتفاع
اكبر في درجات الحراره بمعدل الثلاث الى
اربع درجات مئويه بحلول العام 2050
واشار التقديراتهم الى ان المناطق
الصحراويه في الجزائر والسعوديه والعراق
ستكون في واجهه التاثر بظاهره الاحتباس
الحراري
واذا اضيف الى ذلك الضغط المتزايد على
الموارد المائيه واتساع دائره الجفاف
والتصحر وحرائق الغابات
على مستقبل قاتم مناخيه
نرحب بضيوفنا ثلاثه ونبدا من اللهايه مع
السيد نجيب صعب
امام هذه الصوره القادمه التي تابعناها
كيف يمكن لهذه الدول دول شمال افريقيا
والشرق الاوسط ان تشرع في عمليه التصدي
[موسيقى]
للتعايش مع التغيرات
هناك تدابير عند التكيف المنطقه اساسا
منطقه جافه ولكن
تغير المناخ يزيدها جفافا ويزيد ازمه شح
المياه علينا ان نكون
كفوئين اكثر في استخدام المياه علينا ان
نكون كافئين اكثر في الزراعه ان ننتج كميه
اكبر من الغذاء لاقل كميه من المياه علينا
ان نستعد لارتفاع البحار للاثار على الصحه
علينا ان نستعد الاستعدادات في المنطقه
العربيه شبه معدومه وايضا علينا ان نستعد
في البناء التحتيه في الطرقات شبكات
المياه شبكات كهرباء كلها ستتاثر بالتغير
وما اقوله اخيرا اننا لا ننتظر
اثار تغير المناخ في منطقتنا هذه الاثار
نعيش معها ما يحصل انها ستزداد مع الوقت
المطلوب هو محاوله التكيف الناس للدكتور
زين العابدين الحسيني كيف يمكن التكيفات
او التعايش مع ما ينتظرونا
اظن انه من اللازم ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
العنصر البشري
من حيث التحسيس والتوعيه لانه لا يمكن ان
ننجح في كل المخططات الان البديله وكل
الاجراءات التي يمكن ان تتخذ لمواجهه
الازمه دون نسيان العنصر البشري لان
انخراط العنصر البشري في هذه العمليات
يوفر عوامل يعني النجاح والدعم لكل
المخططات التي وضعت او توضع في هذا الشان
لان الجهود الان
المبذوله هي جهود ضخمه
وكذلك المخططات اا جزء منها فعال
كتيف مع الواقع بحيث ان الدول ذات
الاقتصاد الفلاحي يجب ان تفكر جديا في
تستبدل مجموعه من المزروعات المرتبطه
بالامطار والمرتبطه
اقل حاجه
ولكي يتم ذلك لابد من توعيه الناس الذين
اشتغلوا لعقود ولسنوات على نمط معين من
الانتاج الزراعي ان يكون على وعين تام
باهميته همم الاجراءات التي تتخذ لحمايتهم
وحمايه معيشهم اليومي اضافه الى ان
التقنيات الان المعتمده من تحليه مياه
للبحر الى تدوير او الى اعاده استعمال
المياه كل هذا تتطلب توعيه بحيث لابد من
تجنيد المنظومه
التعليميه المدرسيه كذلك المنظومه
الاعلاميه وهمم الجانب الاكاديمي له دور
مهم في هذا الشان من حيث مراكز البحث او
من حيث الدراسات التي يمكن ان توجد لهذا
الغرض اذا ربما في هذه الحاله سيد كريم
الجندي البدايه يجب ان تكون من هذه النقطه
تحديدا لان في البلاد العربيه تقريبا
قضايا المناخ والحديث على الاحتباس
الحراري وغيره وكانه قضايا النخبويه لا
تهم الناس من اين نبدا في هذه القصه في في
الوعي المجتمعيه هذا الذي يشير اليه دكتور
الحقيقه يعني في رايي ينبغي ان نبدا من
رفع الكفاءه رفع رفع القدره للتكيف في
القضاء وخصوصا في القطاعات التي تتاثر
بشكل اكبر اا بسبب تغير المناخ مش مثل
الزراعه والسياحه همم وقطاعات الاخرى التي
همم يعني فيها هشاشه عاليه لمساله تغير
الملف فبدا بناء القدره بناء على العمل
على بعض القطاعات مثل رفع مثلا كفاءه
استخدام المياه هذه مسائل همم ربما لابد
ان ياخذها بشكل اكثر جدا يعني ربما ايضا
ينبغي علينا مراجعه بعض المشاريع التي لا
تاخذ مساله تغير المناخ في الاعتبار
المشاريع الساحليه التي لا تاخذ مساله
ارتفاع مياه البحر المشاريع التي لا تاخذ
في الاعتبار ملائمه المناخ في المستقبل
همم خمس درجات اعلى همم في همم
لبعض المشاريع التنميه العقاريه على سبيل
المثال او بعض المشاريع التنميه وهي بوجه
عام همم المساله الاخرى التي يريد ان اشير
اليها هي مساله التعاون الحقيقه ان ان
التع ما تغير المناخ كل دوله على حده هي
مساله اصعب كثيره وخصوصا مع تشارك كثير من
دول المنطقه وخصوصا في المشرق وفي شمال
افريقيا في نفس في نفس التحديات فاذا تم
نوع من مشاركه المعلومات او تشارك تشارك
القدرات وتبادل المعلومات وخصوصا في هذه
القضايا المشتركه على سبيل المثال همم
حرائق الغابات او التصحر او همم التعامل
مع مع الجفاف والزراعه بشكل اكثر كفاءه في
استخدام الري كلها كل هذا التشارك من هذه
من في هذه القضايا سيؤدي همم الى تخفيف
هذا الحلم على دول المنطقه يعني اود ان
يشير هنا اننا تاريخ يعني في هذه المنطقه
همم وجدنا ان همم ندره المياه لم تؤدي الى
الاثر السلبي الذي يتوقع في دول في مناطق
اخرى ان انا تاريخيا نظرنا الى حالات
التعاون وحالات الصراع بسبب ازمه ندره
المياه في المنطقه حالات التعاون اكثر من
حالات الصراحه واذا استثنينا الصراع
العربي اسرائيلي من هذه المساله وازمات
المياه التي حدثت همم بين سوريا والاردن
لبنان همم من جهه واسرائيل من جهه اخرى
حول حول المياه في الستينات والسبعينات
القرن الماضي نجد ان الحالات التعاون بين
دول المنطقه الاخرى هي اعلى اعلى واعلى
ربما تؤدي همم اثار تغير المناخ والعمل
المناخي لتجنب اسوا الاثار الى خلق حاله
من الاحتياج من التعاون ربما ان تكون
محفزا بين دول منطقه همم اكثر اكثر من ما
سبق يعني غياب غياب هذا التنسيق الاقليمي
سيدنا نجيب صعب همم اذا كان فعلا مشكله
حقيقيه كيف يمكن لهذه الدول ان ترسي قواعد
للتنسيق من الان همم من اين عليها ان تبدا
اول شيء لنا المشكله ليست فقط التنسيق في
العمل
الاساس والتنسيق في الابحاث العلميه هنا
اذكر قصه مع الدكتور المرحوم محمد القصاص
من اهم علماء العرب في موضوع
الاراضي الجافه اخبرني يوما انه كان في
مؤتمر دولي
حين وجد ان اكثر
بلد متقدم في الابحاث حول الزراعه في
الاراضي الجافه
وفي الزراعه الملحيه كان اسرائيل
علينا ان نعزز البحث العلمي والتعاون في
البحث العلمي في كيفيه مواجهه هذه القناه
وحين نقول التكيف مع التغيرات لا يعني
القبول بالامر الواقع التكيف والاستعداد
لمواجهه هذه التغيرات
ولابد من تعاون اقليمي في هذا المجال على
ذكر البحث العلمي سيد صعب
تقارير تشير الى ان الدول الخليج العربيه
ربما هي الاكثر تاهيلا ان تستثمر وبقوه
ماليه كبيره في هذا المجال في مجال البحث
العلمي لايجاد افضل السبل هل هذا صحيح
انه صحيح جدا من حيث وجود الامكانات
الماليه وانه صحيح ان دول الخليج كثيرا
منها
تقوم الان على تعزير قدراتها المحليه
تعتمد على تشجيع الباحثين المحليين
المواطنين ما احضر منه ان تصرف ميزانيات
البحث العلمي على باحثين اجانب
يبحثون في بلداننا لاستخدام نتائج ابحاث
في بلدانهم على الابحاث العالميه في بلدان
الخليج وبلدان العربيه بشكل عام ان يتم
استخدامها في هذه البلدان وان تستجيب
لحاجه هذه البلدان واذا كان من الوقت
اعطيك مثلا في الكويت مثلا هناك كل سنه او
سنتين
لالاف اطنان الاسماك
قليلا ما نسمع عن ابحاث العلميه في الكويت
تحدث سبب هذه المشكله مع ان هناك
مئات الملايين تصرف على الابحاث العلميه
علينا ان نوجه نبحث العلميه في بلداننا في
حي المشاكلنا وان نشجع مواطنين على القيام
بهذه الابطال بالنسبه للتنسيق الاقليمي
الدكتور زين العابدين الحسيني
يعني بالنسبه لدول مثل المغرب والجزائر
وتونس سبت فيها حرائق غابات كثيره وهناك
امكانيه للتعاون في هذا المجال الاقل وفي
مجله اخرى بالنسبه للمستقبل كيف يمكن لهذه
الدول ان تتجاوز الخلافات السياسيه
الظرفيه لارسال قواعد عمل لمساله التغير
المناخي والتنسيق فيما بينها مثلا
ربما نتفائل ونقول ان هذا الموضوع الهام
والخطير جدا يمكن ان يشكل مستقبلا عامل
اقناع لمن لازال يتردد في اهميه التعاون
الاقليمي ذلك انه كما تفضلتم على مستوى
دول المغرب العربي هناك تشابه كبير في
مساله ندره الماء وما يعرفوه بالاجهاد
المائي غير ان على مستوى المملكه المغربيه
هناك حقيقه
جهود مهمه جدا همم تستعين كذلك بالخبره
الاكاديميه وبالجامعه في هذه المجال نذكر
على سبيل المثال على ان الاقليم الجنوبيه
في المغرب الان تصدر بعض المنتجات
الفلاحيه التي تنتج في هذه الاقاليم بناء
على انماط من السقي همم تقوم اساسا على
الاستعمال المعقلا وترشيد المياه بشكل
كبير ما يحدث في عده دول اسبانيا مثلا
التي تنتج في منطقه الميريا وهي منطقه شبه
الصحراويه الكثير من الفواكه والثمار
بكميه قليله من الماء هذا التجربه ناجحه
في الاقاليم الجنوبيه للمملكه كما انه على
مستوى اخر مستوى ما يعرف بتحريه ماء البحر
او ازاله الملوحه فالجامعه المغربيه
بتعاون مع الجهات المختص استطاعات مثلا ان
تسقيه المناطق الخضراء في العاصمه الرباط
التي الان تعد من العواصم التي تحترم
النسبه التي تحددها الامم المتحده وكذلك
منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه فيما يخص نسبه همم
المساحات الخضراء بالنسبه لكل مواطن ولها
معدلات مرتفعه الان اكثر من 80% من
المساحات الخضراء الكثيره الموجوده
بالرباط تسقى من المياه المعالجه هذه
التجربه من المفروض ان نتقاسمها اولا معها
منطقه هنا التي تشبهنا في كثير من من
الاشياء على مستوى الازمه وهذا امر حقيقه
غير موجود حاليا ولكن نتمنى نتمنى ان شاء
الله ان ان ينتشر اهتمام وان يقتنع ال ال
الشركاء والجيران باهميه هذا الموضوع لانه
ليست ليس عندنا بدائل كثيره امام هذه
الاسماء امام هذا التناقص المتعاظم
والمتسارع في الموارد المائيه وامام كذلك
كثره الطلب وكثره الحاجيات ان على مستوى
الغذاء او على مستوى الماء الشروب الذي لا
يمكنه ان تستقيم الحياه بدونه كما يعلم
الجميع همم استعملت كلمه الاجهاد المائي
الذي اريد ان اتحدث فيه مع سيد كريم
الجندي همم جهاد المائي هو المقصود به
يعني همم تناقص كميات الامطار مع مشكله
حتى في المياه الجوفيه نظرا ل- اا كميه
استنفادها همم البعض يطرح امكانيه تغير في
التوجبات الزراعيه الصحه التعبير في
المغرب مثلا همم هناك حديث عن من الانسب
زراعه الشعير عوض القمح في بعض المناطق
بالنسبه لمصر مثلا في فتره من فترات ورغم
وجود النيل هناك حديث عن ضروره همم
التقليل من استعمال كميات المياه كيف يمكن
ال- ال- ال- ال- ال- التوصل الى حلول في
هذا السياق
هو تناقص نسبه نصيب الفرد من المياه همم
الاجمالا موارد المياه للفرد همم فعندما
تصل الى اقل من حد معين فهي همم تسبب
مشكله بسبب همم عدم توفر المياه اللازمه
للزراعه بشكل اساسي همم مشكله الزراعه في
المنطقه ليست فقط تناقص الموارد للفرد همم
في المنطقه فقدت قدرتها على انتاج غذائها
لنفسها منذ منذ عقود الحقيقه ولكن بسبب
بسبب همم
تزايد السكان همم
ومحدوديه المياه ان ان لم تكن تتناقص ولكن
المشكله الاخرى الاضافيه لان دول المنطقه
حوالات كثيره من موارد المياه اللي زراعه
منتجات يمكن تصديرها لانها تدر همم العمله
الصعبه على هذه الدول ولم تعد تعمل بشكل
اساسي على توفير الامن الغذائي للدوليها
لم تعد تنتج همم القمح الشعير على سبيل
المثال وهنا هنا التحدي عندما همم تقل يقل
الامن الغذائي اللي هو تعتمد على
الاستيراد ال- ال- الغذاء الاساسي لا قبل
الحصول على بعض همم الاموال نتيجه لتصدير
بعض المنتجات الخاصه التي تستخدم كثيرا من
المياه همم يحدث مشكلتين تنقص المياه
المتاحه همم والمشكله الاخرى انما انت
عندما يحدث اي اضطراب لمنظومه همم الغذاء
العالمي همم كما راينا بعيده الحرب في
اوكرانيا همم لا توجد الموارد الغذائيه
الاساسيه التي يمكن همم يمكن ان توفر
الغذاء لدول المنطقه
فالتحول ال- همم المرجو لقطاع الزراعه في
المنطقه هو اكثر تعقيدا مما نتمنى ليست
فقط مساله همم
للراي اكثر كفاءه ولكن ايضا تغيير لما
يمكننا زراعته في همم في في في دول
المنطقه همم والتعامل مع مع تربه المنطقه
التي اعيدت تتعرض بكثير من من التحديات
يعني هو اللي وضع استراتيجيه من هذا
القبيل همم سيد جندي يعني مثلا الرئيس
السابق التونسي منصف المرزوق
دعا الى همم عقد مؤتمر وطني في تونس مؤتمر
اثنين يبحث هذه الاستراتيجيات على المدام
المتوسط والبعيد بعيدا عن اي مماحاكاه
سياسيه هل يمكن للدول العربيه ان ان تشرع
فعلا في مبادرات من هذا القبيل لان الوقت
يمر والمستقبل مظلم
نعم بدون شك ولكن يوجد سقف للنجاح في هذا
القطاع سقف فيها النجاح في القطاع من
المنطقه غير قاضيه على على توفير غذائها
لنفسها اا يعني ربما باستثناء همم الدول
مثل السودان ولكن اجمالا شمال افريقيا همم
والمشرق وبدون شك من الدول الخليج غير
قادر على انتاج غذائها لنفسيه بشكل همم
يغفر لها الامن الغذائي فيمكن التعاون
للتقليل من الحته هذا الامر التكيف مع مع
تغير المناخ واثاره السلبيه على هذا
القطاع الاساسي ولكن لا ننتظر من هكذا
مؤتمرات وهكذا مبادرات توفير الامن
الغذائي المنطقه هذه هذه الحقيقه مع الاسف
نعم اذا اردنا ان ننظر همم للمنطقه كيف
يمكن ان تصبح همم سيد نجيب صعب اذا لم
ناخذ الامور بجديه يعني انطلاقا له الان
سيد جندي همم يعني ربما يذو الناس في فتره
سيتراجع على القطاع الزراعي بشكل كبير
وهمم ويصبح الناس امام ازمه جوع في شمال
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
واعطيك مثلا عن قضيه كنت دائما اطرحها
وكان يدعمني فيها الدكتور محمد القصاص
والدكتور مصطفى طلبه في مصر والا لما كنت
نفذت في جلدي فيها
في مصر مثلا يعتبر
الارز هو الوجبه القوميه كنا نقول دائما
منذ سنوات
اسباب غذائيه اخرى تستهلك كميه اقل من
المياه وتعطي القيمه الغذائيه نفسها اذا
اضطررتنا بذلك لم نكن لكم انه علينا ان
نفعل هذا من اليوم ولكن ان نكون مستعدين
فانا اؤيد ما جاء في كلام زميلين علينا
الا نفكر فقط في اساليب الزراعه والري
ولكن في استبدال بعض انواع المحاصيل علينا
ان لا نبدا الان ولكن ان تكون مستعدين
خيارات متطرفه خيارات متطرفه قد مضطر
اليها ولكن لكم مستعدين لها منذ الان وكما
تقول انا معك اذا لم نفعل هذا اذا لم
نعزز البحث العلمي والتعاون والتغيير
الجذري في اداره المياه والزراعه قد نصل
الى يوم نواجه فيه الجوع
هذا ما تواجهه كثير من البلدان الان ولو
لم يكن في بعض ولداننا ثروه بتروليه لكن
اسوا من بعض الدول التي تواجه اسوا اسباب
الجوع والمجرات من الاثار السلبيه التي
تنتظرون ايضا دكتور زين العابدين موضوع
موجات هجره وموجات نزوح يعني حسب بعد
التقارير الدوليه بحلول عام 2050 سيجهاجر
اكثر من 200 مليون بسبب التغيرات المناخيه
وزهاء العشرين مليون في منطقه شمال
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط بسبب الاوضاع
المناخيه كيف يمكن ان ان ان ان ان ان ان
نستعد لشيء من هذا القبيل
اه بدايه اود ان اضيف شيئا بخصوص الاجهاد
المائي هناك معدلات وضعتها الامم المتحده
في هذا الخصوص وهو نسبه حظ الفرد السنوي
من الماء
فالمعدلات التي تنخفض على 800 متر مكعب
فهي ااا تدخل في اطار الاجهاد المائي
حاليا على مستوى الدول المغرب العربي فنحن
بين
450 في الجزائر وتونس وحوالي 600 في
المغرب هذا من جاء من جهه اخرى المساله
التي اثرتم من حيث الهجره نحن الان نشاهد
ان الخريطه السكانيه الديموغرافيه تتغيروا
من همم من طاقته الى اخرى بحيث هناك نزوح
من همم الجنوب الى الشمال همم في اتجاه
المناطق التي لا تزال التساقطات المطريه
فيها
يعني في معدلات
مهمه
تجعلوا ان الساكنه بشكل طبيعي وغريزي
تنتقل من المناطق يعني الجافه والقاحله
الى المناطق الممطره وهو ما يشكل يعني
مجموعه من التحديات ومشاكل كثيره بالنسبه
للحكومات بالنسبه للاداره بصفه عامه بحيث
ان هذه الامر يطرح اشكال كبيرا على مستوى
التنميه على مستوى معدلات التنميه البشريه
على مستوى يعني
ناتج الاجمالي اضافه الى المشاكل الامنيه
والصحيه الى غير ذلك مما يعرقل النمو
يعني يشكلوا ارتباكا في مخططات التنميه
بحيث ان هذه المخططات عندما وضعت لم تكون
تستحضر في تلك اللحظه هذه المشاكل التي
همم لا اقول انها قرات بشكل مفاجئ ولكن
هناك تسارع كبير فيما وصلنا اليه
هذا من شهام من جهه اخرى فان ال همم يعني
تطور الديموغرافي الحاصل همم على مستوى
الدول المغرب العربي وخصوصا في المغرب
يعني يتسبب حتى في مشاكل على مستوى
العلاقات الدوليه
فالشواطئ الشماليه المغرب مليئه بلاجئين
المناخ الان هذا المصطلح اصبح يستعمل
واستعمل في همم مؤتمر شرم الشيخ الذي
ينتهي غدا بحيث اصبح ظاهره دوليه وهذه
مساله كان قد اشار اليها الامين العام
السابق والامم المتحده كوفي عنان في مقال
ان له صدر بالوشن بوست بعد ان يعني همم
انتهت مهامه يقول على انه الان جل الازمات
الموجوده في افريقيا وخصوص شمال افريقيا
سببها المناخ وسببها المناخ اذا فنحن الان
امام يعني ازمه متعدده الروافد متعدده
النتائج والتظهرات يرتبط فيها ما هو
ديموغرافي بما هو اقتصادي بما هو صناعي ما
هو بيئي وحتى ايضا بما هو صحي مما يستدعي
ان نتعامل مع المشكل بجد وان همم يعني همم
نقتنع همم مره واحده على اننا فعلا امام
مشكلين يهم الجميع وليس فقط الحكومات او
الادارات المعنيه بالتنميه الدكتور حسين
ايضا التقارير تشير بان المتوسط حوض
المتوسط مستوى المياه فيه يرتفع اكثر من
اي مكان اخر
وفي ضوء حديث عن ان مدينه مثل الاسكندريه
ستتضرر كثيرا او مدينه مثل البصره في جنوب
العراق بالنسبه لحوض المتوسط والدول
المغاربيه تحديدا ما الذي ينتظرها
هذه الظاهره هي ظاهره
عالميه عامه نذكر على ان الكوب ااا 24 او
23 المنعقده في المانيا هي
يعني المتحده هذه الدوره دوره الاطراف
كانت منظمه من طرف جزيره فيدجي ونظمت في
المانيا نظمت من طرف في جزيره في جيب
النظر الى ان الان الدول الجزريه جزء كبير
منها مهدده بالاختفاء بسبب ذوبان الجليد
في القطب المتجمد الشمالي ذوبان الجليد في
كل القمم والجبال الاوروبيه التي كان فيها
الجليد على امتداد السنه
فالروافد الان والانهار التي تصب في
المتوسط
والصبيب الان الذي يميز هذا همم هذا
الصبيب او هذا الظاهره ادت الى ارتفاع
منسوب البحار والمحيطات بصفه عامه وهو كما
تفضلتهم يهدد كثير الشواطئ بزحف المياه
على كثير من المناطق التي همم مستقبلا وفي
افق سنه 2050 ربما قد تختفي بسبب هذه
الظاهره وهو ما يجعلنا يعني نوحد الجهود
من اجل خفض حراره الارض لانه الحل الوحيد
الان هو ان ينفذ ما تم
الاتفاق عليه في باريس 2015 في مؤتمر
الاطراف ال 21 لكي نعمل جميعا على همم
الحد او التخفيض من الغازات الدفيئه ومن
الاحتباس الحراري من خلال خفض درجه حراره
الارض التي لا تزال في ارتفاع المهبل
ومخيف لا يمكنه لاحد ان يسكت يعني كما
اشار الى ذلك الامر الامم المتحده في
الخطاب الافتتاح
مؤتمر الشيخ حيث قال ربما نحن متوجهون الى
عمليتين انتحاريه لكن حتى قبل الانتحاريه
هناك حديث همم سيد كريم الجندي عن ان
المستقبل يخبا لنا الكثير من النزاعات
وحتى الحروب بسبب ندره المياه كيف يمكن ل-
اا المناخ ان يتحول الى عنصر توفير في
العلاقات بين الدول الى هذا الحد
نعم حقيقه اثار تغير المناخ الاساسيه يعني
معروفه للجميع ولدينا ثقه عاليه في ما
سيحدث ولكن الاثار الثانويه لتغير المناخ
الاثار التقاطعاتها مع الجوانب الاقتصاديه
والجوانب الاجتماعيه مثل اثرها على
القطاعات الاساسيه مثل الزراعه والسياحه
اثرها على الامن الغذائي اا تفضلت حضرتك
بذكر امم ان الناس ربما قد يمر بفترات من
الجوع هذا لا اعتقد انه سيحدث يمكن
استيراد هذا الغذاء ولكن ما سيحدث في
دولتنا ستصبح افقر نتيجه لهذا الاحتياج
الاضافي
لاستيراد الغذاء همم هذه التقاطعات ونضيف
لها ايضا همم تحول الطاقه العالمي همم
والبعد التدريجي او تخفيف التدريجي من
استخدام همم الوقود الاحفوري النفط والغاز
همم سيؤثر على اقتصاديه الدول المنطقه
المعتمده على هذا على هذه على هذه
الصادرات من همم ليست فقط همم من ناحيه
اداره اقتصاده اقتصاديتها همم ولكن ايضا
ااا عقدها الاجتماع يعتمد على توزيع هذا
الريان الذي تحصل عليه من من تصدير النفط
والغاز والغاز همم الاثار الثانويه من
ناحيه الاقتصاديه همم والاجتماعيه على دول
منطقه ربما ستكون الاكثر انيه والاكثر
حظورا اا في السيارات القادمه وليست في
الماده الطويل مثل الاثار الاساسيه التي
تحدثنا عنها بدايه من الحراره
والنقص في في الامطار وارتفاع مياه البحار
وهكذا الجانب الثالث او الاثار الثالث
ربما تكون هي الاقل همم
بوضوحا لنا همم يعني ماذا سيحدث ان زادت
نسبه البطاله نتيجه لاثار على قطاعات
الزراعه او قطاعات السياحه على سبيل
المثال هل سيؤتي ذلك الى نوع من الاحتقان
الاجتماعي كما راينا في سوريا من ناحيه
هجره ثمانيه الف شخص من من من الريف الى
المدن همم عدم وجود خدمات كافيه لهم عدم
وجود وظائف ااا كافيه لهم اا هل هل ستؤدي
الى اام نوع معين من التباين من اثار تغير
المناخ في منطقه همم تابعه لطائفه معينه
او و و اثار اقل في منطقه تابعه لمنطقه
لطائفه اخرى هل سيؤدي هذا لزياده في
الاحتقان بين بين هذين هاتين الطائفتين في
دول المنطقه على سبيل المثال هل هل سيؤدي
الصراعات على المياه همم كما كما ذكرنا
مسبقا الى نزاع حول الموارد الطبيعيه بين
بين دول المنطقه هذا الذي ليس لدينا وضوح
كافي همم فيما يتعلق بامكانيات حدوثه هو
ولكن كل اثار تغير المناخ تهيئ ال همم
الارض نحو حدوث همم هكذا همم هكذا تحولات
سلبيه هل ستحدث هل تحتاج الى شرر
ايديولوجي يؤدي يؤدي الى هذه الصراعات
يؤدي الى هذه النزاعات سواء في في الدوله
الواحده او بين او بين الدول هذا غير واضح
لنا ولكن يعني همم سمحت يعني هذه المنطقه
هي ضحيه لتغيير المناخ نعم اثر اثار
التغير المناخ على المنطقه غير متناسبه مع
مسؤوليتها تاريخيه غير متناسبه مع حجمها
من الاقتصاد العالمي مع حجمها من سكان
العالم هذا بدون شك ولكن المنطقه يعني لا
ينبغي ان تظل مفعولا بها طوال الوقت حتى
في ملف تغير منها يمكن ان تكون فاعله ايضا
ان شاءت همم تحويل اقتصادها ليس فقط من
ناحيه تنميه الاقتصاد والبعد عن الاقتصاد
الرايعي المعتمد على تصدير النفط والغاز
ولكن ايضا تحويله لاقتصاد منخفض الكربون
هذا هذا التحول وان كان ليس في اولويات
المنطقه التي هي الان بالاساس همم النحو
التكييف ولكن سيسمح للمنطقه ان يكون لها
مقعد على طاوله وضع قواعد الاقتصاد العالم
الجديد الذي يتم تطويره هل هذه القواعد لم
توضع حتى الان ولمن تقع وهي خارجها ليس
لها صوت ان ان وضعت همم لها همم وجدت لها
مكان على هذه الطاوله يمكنها ان تشكل هذا
الاقتصاد العالمي الجديد الذي من تشكيله
وهذا ي- ينقلها من وضع الضحيه الى وضع همم
الفاعل الايجابي في محاربه هذا الملف ليس
فقط اقلاميا ولكن ايضا عالميا وتاكيدا
لانها ضحيه همم حسب التقارير انه مع نهايه
القرن همم 80% تقريبا من المدن الكبرى في
شمال افريقيا وشرق الاوسط ستعاني من موجه
حر شديده وشديد للغايه اكبر من اي معدلات
سابقه همم سيد همم نجيب صعب همم هل هذا
نوع من القدر الذي لا يمكن تغييره او يمكن
ان يغير ولكن بنسبه طويله
لنكن واقعيين هناك تغييرات مناخيه
تاثيراتها لن يمكن ركبها انها ستحصل
البحار سترتفع الى درجه معينه الفارق انه
حين نخفف الانبعاثات الان على مستوى عالمي
يمكن ان نضع حدا لهذا الارتفاع ارتفاع
البحار مثلا نتكلم عن الاسكندريه وكانها
لا خلاص لها ابدا وانها بعد 50 عاما قد
يغرق معظمها
نقول التكيف معنى الاستعداد هولندا مثلا
حيث انا الان معظمها تحت مستوى البحر
ولكنها تعيش من دمياط السنين ببناء
الحواجز البحريه وبناء السدود
ليه صد المياه في الاسكندريه مثلا من الان
يجب القيام بتدابير
لبناء حواجز مياه البحر كما في هولندا
الكارثه الكبرى ليست قدرا
التغيرات بعضها سيحصل ولكن يمكننا
الاستعداد للتصدي لها وعلينا ان نفعل هذا
ابتداء من هذه اللحظه
هل يمكن التعويل دكتور زين العابدين
الحسين هل يمكن التعاويل على الدعم الدولي
لهذه المنطقه يعني هناك صندوق يسمى صندوق
التكيف العالمي وهو مخصص للدول الناميه
لمواجهه تداعيات التغير المناخي يعني
المانيا مثلا دفعت في مؤتمر شرم الشيخ 60
مليون يورو لهذا الصندوق هل لا يمكن لي
دول شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط ان تعول
بدرجه او باخرى على هذا الصندوق او على
غيره من المساعدات
ما ينص عليه الواقع او ما نستشفه من
الواقع يعني حقيقه لا يبشر بخير ولا يمكنه
ان يجيب بالايجاب بالنظر الى ان مشكل
تمويل منذ
المؤتمر دوره 22 مرورا بجلاس قوه الى شرم
الشيخ المشكل هو في التزام الدول المانحه
والدول الاكثر تلوثا والاكثر غنانا
بالمساهمه في هذا الصندوق الذي تفضلتم
بالاشارات اليه همم ما تخوله او ما تساهم
به الدول التي التزمت
بتمويلها هذا الصندوق يقل كثيرا عما ينبغي
ان تمنحه فعلا وقد جاءت فتره ترامب في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لتزيد الطين
بالله عندما قاطع او عندما خرج من عهد من
معاهده باريس
وادى الى
كثير من ال من ال يعني السلبيه
وشجع بعض الدول المتردده في المساهمه
انسحبت يعني المساهماتها كما حدث بالنسبه
لكندا وغيرها وبالتالي مساله التمويل هذه
مساله تبقى جد نسبيه ويبقى على هذه الدول
ان تعول على امكانياتها الذاتيه وعلى
اتفاقيه الثنائيه
والمتعدده الاطراف التي يمكن ان تبرمها في
هذا الصدد وعلى التكليف وتحويل صناعتها
بالصوره التي تضمن من جهه بقاء
الاستثمارات الدوليه الموجوده لديها مع
امكانيه الانضباط لبعض يعني الشروط وبعد
الاحتياطات التي لابد من اخذها في عين
الاعتبار
لا اقول لمنع وانما للتقليل من هذه
الانعكاسات السلبيه للافرازات الغازيه
وهنا لابد ان نذكر على ان
الجهود التي بدلت في هذه المؤتمرات
مؤتمرات الاطراف تبقى بالرغم من ان هذه
الاطراف يعني متعدده بالاضافه الى الاطراف
المؤسسات المؤسساتين والدوليين هناك
المجتمع المدنيين هناك الشركات الكبرى الى
غير ذلك ولكن دائما يبقى على كاهل
الحكومات الا ان الفاعل الاقتصادي
والمستثمرين دائما ما يكونون في همم يعني
مؤخره الركب بحيث ان نتائج هذه المؤتمرات
كما يحدث حاليا في شرم الشيخ تكون جد
نسبيه اذا ما راينا ماده التلوث الذي
تسببت في تسبب في هذه الجمع من حيث وسائل
النقل من حيث استعمالات المختلفه للطاقات
التي همم كانت لابد منها للقيام بعمل
المؤتمر وبالتالي هذه المساله كما ذكرت
نسبيه جدا ولكن كيف يمكن همم لهذه الدول
سيد كريم الكندي ان تعول على امكانياتها
مثل ما يقول الدكتور الحسيني وهي الدول في
معضمها اذا استثنينا دول الخليج العربيه
دول منهمك اقتصاديا فيها ازمات غذا فيها
ازمات حليب في ازمات وقود كيف يمكن
للحكومات ان تفكر في مستقبل بعد 50 سنه
وترصد له الميزانيات وتعمل عليه من الان
وهي
غارقه في شان اليومي وتدبير الشان اليوم
الحقيقه ان هذا هو التحدي الاكبر بطبيعه
الحال والدول الدول المتاثره بتغير المناخ
الدول الدول الناميه اتفقت في اتفاقيه
يعني تسمى الاتفاقيه الكبرى في في صلب في
صلب المفاوضات المناخ انا انها ستساعد
الدول المتقدمه فيما يتعلق بالملف التخفيف
افضل الانبعاثات ولكن الدول المتقدمه او
الاقتصاديات المتقدمه على الجانب الاخر
ستوفر التمويل اللازم والذي لم ياتي يعني
حتى الان الصوره التي وعد بها مبدايا
ايضا ستوفر او همم بدات نقاشه حول توفير
تعويضات همم للخسائر والاضرار التي لا
يمكن التكيس معها همم هذا ان هو من
التعويض همم ليس فقط تمويل للمشاريع ولكنه
تعويض لاثار تغير من هناك على دول المنطقه
يعني على مثلا همم على همم الفيضان
الفيضانات التي رايناها في تكستان على
سبيل المثال ان تمرقتها بتغير المناخ
فيمكن ان الحصول على تعويضات نتيجه نتيجه
لذلك وليس يعني هنا الا ان اذكر همم
مبا الشرق الاوسط الكبير التي التي بدات
من همم من اداره الشرق الاوسط معذره التي
بداتها السعوديه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه العام الماضي وبدات ترتسم همم
ملامحها هذا العام في في مؤتمر الاطراف
وهي توفر بعض التمويل لدول الدول المنطقه
ليست كل دول المنطقه ولكن لديها دعم كبير
من الدول رايناه من تمثيل رؤساء دول في في
في في في في بدايه هذا بدايه طرح هذه
المباراه العام الماضي في يوجد نوع من
التمويل الداخلي يمكن ان يحدث من من
اقليميه على مستوى المستوى المنطقه ويوجد
ايضا همم دعم سواء من همم دعم تمويل همم
كجزء من الايطاليه لتغير المناخ ويوجد ملف
جديد وهو ملف التعويض همم الذي الذي بدا
مؤخرا وراينا دفع قويه من الدول الناميه
في هذا المؤتمر في في شرم الشيخ همم
الرئاسه المؤتمر المصريه يعني همم
مشكوره قامت بدور الكبير من اجل وضعها على
همم جدول الاعمال هذا العام برغم معارضه
امريكيه اوروبيه شديده
لخشيه ان يكون هناك التزاما قانونيا همم
في المستقبل يعني بتعويضات ربما لا قبل
لهم
كل ذلك الا ان يعني بدات المفاوضات هذا
العام همم الاسبوع الماضي همم
للنقاش حول ما ما نوع التمويل الذي يستحصل
عليه الدول الناميه من نوع التعويض مع
ذرات التي تحصل عليه الدول الناميه وعن
همم اليات توفير هذا التعويض فتوجد عند
الطرق للتعامل مع هذه المشكله التي طرحتها
وهي الدول الناميه ليست لديها القدره
الماديه وليس لديها قدره التقنيه للتعامل
مع مشاكلها القائمه وايضا مع مشكله
التغيرات المناخ شكرا جزيلا لك همم الكريم
الجندي الكبير في شؤون البيئه
شكرا
لضيفنا من تطوان همم الدكتور زين العابدين
الحسين الخبير في التشريع البيئي
والتغيرات المنا
ولضيفنا من لهايب همم نجيب صعب الامين
العام للمنتدى العربي للبيئه والتنميه
ورئيس تحرير مجله البيئه والتنميه شكرا
لكم جميعا
كالعاده ننتقل الى تغريدات حول موضوع هذه
الحلقه والبدايه بتغريده لمنظمه تكريم بيس
البيئيه جاء فيها يتعين على قاده العالم
ادراك ان ازمه المناخي ازمه حقوق انسان
وان حمايه هذه الحقوق تبدا بدعم المجتمعات
والبلدان الفقيره التي تتحمل بالفعل وطئه
ازمه المناخ وذلك من خلال الزام الدول
الاكثر ثراءا بدفع فاتوره الخسائر
والاضرار التي تسببت بها على امتداد عقود
طويله
الامين العام للامم المتحده قال في احد
تغريداته بمناسبه بمؤتمر المناخ كوب 27
يقول ازمه المناخيه معركه حياتنا ونحن
نخسر لكن هناك شيء واحد مؤكد اولئك الذين
يستسلمون سيخسرون بالتاكيد لذلك دعونا
نقاتل معانا نفوز
اما رئيس البرازيلي الجديد الذي سيلفا
فذكر باخفاق الاطراف المشاركه في مؤتمر
كوبنهاجي القائلا في عام 2009 تعاهدت
الدول الحاضره في الدوره الخامسه عشر
للمؤتمر الاطراف بالتبرع بمبلغ 100 مليار
دولار سنويا بحلول عام 2020 وذلك لمساعده
البلدان الاقل نموا على مواجهه تغير
المناخ لكن لم يتم الوفاء بهذا الالتزام
حتى الان
ونختم بهذه التغريده لمنظمه الاغذيه
والزراعه للامم المتحده تقول فيها التنوع
البيولوجي يفقد بمعدل يندره يفقد بمعدل
ينظر بالخطر يندر بالخطر عفوا وتغير
المناخ يزيد الامر سوءا نعتمد على التنوع
البيولوجي من اجله طعام الذي ناكله
والهواء الذي نتنافسه والماء الذي نشرب
بدونها تنعدم الحياه كما نعرفها
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع
المقبل باذن الله في موضوع جديد وبحث عن
سيناريوهاتن مستقبليه جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]